she can work nine to five and rock a
coat of many colors dolly in 2024 y'all
welcome everybody to Entertainment
Tonight you know on this President's Day
we're opening up the E.T Vault to
celebrate someone who's beloved on both
sides of the aisle because in Dolly We
Trust
[Music]
everything else that's happened to me
has come from the music I love to write
that's my gift you were meant to be a
songwriter well I don't know how good I
am I got about 3 000 songs 25 country
number one singles 10 Grammys over 100
million records sold Dolly's prolific
music career spans eight decades
[Music]
it was my songs My songwriting that
brought me out of Smoky Mountains and
took me all the places I want to go I
wish you
[Music]
I will always love you was a a song that
I was real recognized for and it was one
of the that and Jolene was uh one of the
two of the biggest songs I had ever had
and uh but they didn't sell any records
They both only sold like a hundred
thousand copies which I ain't enough to
feed my chickens and I just always
thought that song deserved more I just
thought that it was a hit if somebody
else would record it
I
will always love me
I listened to it and I said this is the
song this will tie that whole movie
together as far as the music is
concerned Whitney's version recorded for
The Bodyguard spent 14 weeks at number
one and became the best-selling single
by a female artist Whitney did a
fabulous job on that I never had any
idea that simple little song of mine
could do that but she made it something
special Dolly shared special moments
with some of the most iconic artists in
the biz with over 50 collaborations
across genres and generations
[Music]
she doesn't really let me call her a
godmother she likes Fairy Godmother I
feel like a member of people's family
like an Aunt Dolly or like a you know
like an older sister maybe I'm a role
model and I hope so
here you come again a woman who has been
successful in everything she's ever done
just a role model for girls including
myself Dolly shattered all of those
illusions of what a genre and what a
boundary was she's never made any
apologies for who she is and that's my
favorite kind of artist
Valley skyrocketed to a new level of
stardom when she set her sights on
Hollywood
there's no such thing as natural beauty
somebody would did you honestly know you
were going to be a star I believe I did
that's what I wanted to do I always felt
that I was supposed to do it because I
wanted to be famous I wanted to be rich
Dolly's breakout role in the 1980 comedy
classic nine to five earned her three
Golden Globe nominations
and the anthem she penned while filming
turned the movie into a movement earning
her the first of two Oscar nominations
and two Grammys on you just love it
don't you
goodbye see I wrote it it's playing with
my nails
[Music]
it meant a lot to me the fact that it
brought attention to all those gals
asking for equal pay for equal work and
it has done a lot of good
bye
Dolly scored her second Best Actress
Golden Globe not two years later for the
movie musical The Best Little Whorehouse
in Texas
[Music]
although it was successful money-wise it
it wasn't really that you know that
great as far as the critics and
everybody was concerned she bounced back
with another female driven hit Steel
Magnolias she told E.T she went to
beauty school for the role this is going
in the hairdo Hall of Fame now I'm
having to cut everybody's hair I've
become like a beautician in my own
family my husband won't ever let anybody
cut his hair again I really I've acted
myself into a corner
throughout her more than 40 years in the
business Dolly's made over 400 TV
appearances and starred in over a dozen
feature films I'd like to think with me
you know there'll always be something I
can play just because I'm Dolly Parton
that's been around for a hundred years
and personally I have been waiting for a
nine to five reunion ever since we did
the first one dollies reunited with Jane
and Lily more than seven times and when
it comes to a reboot I didn't want to do
a sequel myself it's like I don't like
to chew my tobacco but once we haven't
been able to get a script that we were
satisfied with if you don't have the
script you can't start and we're trying
to make it happen before one of us
checks out we've met jokes now to do a
remake of nine to five would be more
like 95.
okay
with the rise of Dolly's career came her
signature style I'm kind of a cartoon
I'll probably look this way when I'm 100
if I lived be that long three words to
describe my style trashy trashy trashy
what's your secret oh there's no real
secret just lots of makeup and good
doctors and a good attitude
[Music]
everybody knows Dolly wears great big
wonderful wigs and tight clothes and
heavy makeup why did you decide to look
like you look most of it came from a
very sincere place because I felt very
plain I felt very big inside and very
outgoing and I just didn't feel like I
was all on the outside that I was on the
inside so I wanted the attention I don't
feel cheap but I don't mind looking
cheap she doesn't feel cheap because
that famous figure costs a pretty penny
I'm no natural beauty oh that's makeup
Botox and collagen and other nips and
Tucks people always say oh you just
always seem so happy I see that is the
botox I heard that you look at your
boobs as show dogs or show horses right
and you say you have to keep them
groomed oh I do I call these my weapons
of mass just
her breasts are so small they look like
melons
more secrets about Dolly's aesthetic is
it true that you sleep with your makeup
on dollar I do you never know what's
gonna happen I get up in the morning I
clean my face I do my math and then I
put on fresh makeup yeah but I never I'm
not going to bed you know looking like a
hag I just ain't gonna do it I'm just
going to be ready because there's a fire
or a flood or an emergency her beauty
routine is surprisingly quick I wear
wigs a lot I do my own makeup I can be
completely ready with everything within
an hour less if need be oh and Miss
Dolly almost always keeps her arms and
hands covered often wearing these nude
gloves why fans think you have
full-fledged sleeves you've got tattoos
is this true I do have a few tattoos
emotionally two covers some scars from
surgeries I just sit in the flowers some
Vines and a butterfly here and there
what do you think makes a woman pretty
well the woman from the inside is the
prettiest part I think what radiates
from the inside out like Minnie Pearl
says I mean any old barn looks better
with a little red paint on it
[Music]
Dolly's husband of 56 years Carl Dean
may be the only person who's seen her
without all that paint this glamorous
Dolly Parton image must have at times
been a little intimidating not really he
knows how bad I can look
the two met outside a laundromat in
Nashville in 1964. dolly was 18 and he
was 21. two years later they eloped in
Georgia when we got married Carl put the
wedding rings on his mother's serious
account so we paid on that every month
then years later I after we were making
some money I I lost a little set out of
the original and I was just heartbroken
and I thought oh how can you ever
replace that so he went back down to
Sears and and bought the stone to
replace it and and paid on it even
though we didn't have to just so it
would it kind of still stay like that
for a while the couple's very private
marriage had some fans thinking Carl
doesn't really exist why is he such a
mystery he's too pretty I'm afraid to
let him out he's never really
photographed a Mythic creature at this
point
he does not want to be um in pictures he
don't want to be a magazine he don't
want to be Dolly Parton's husband he
wants to be Carl Dean
the camera shy businessman is now
retired at 80 and while Dolly became a
global Superstar Carl stayed focused on
his Tennessee pavement company we have
the greatest relationship because first
of all we're best friends we really are
both very independent people I need the
freedom to work he needs the freedom to
work I want him to do exactly what makes
him happy in 2015 E.T was with Dolly who
revealed how they plan to celebrate
their 50th wedding anniversary we're
going to get married again and we're
going to get in our RV and go on a
honeymoon we got all dressed up he was
so handsome and I had him my beautiful
gown that I didn't get to do before and
he tells everybody I'm his second wife
what's been the key to success well I
always joke because I stay gone and
there's a lot of Truth in that I love
the old guy he's the only one I've ever
wanted and the only one I'll ever have
we cannot leave without celebrating one
more Dolly Parton achievement yes adding
the title of Dolly
dolly
[Music]
fallible it is happening summer or fall
I'm doing a lot of classic rock songs
and I'm having a lot of Icon singers
sing with me like Elton John like Paul
McCartney Stevie Nicks pink and Cher
Miley Cyrus Molly of course though she's
going rock Dolly has no plans to tour
again as for what's next well it's the
same thing she told us back in 1982. I
do work hard but I like to work and I
learned while I was off the road that I
will never retire I I like the work Ah
that's true I'll never retire I feel the
same exact way I love to work
foreign